so it's 7:00 a.m. the wired crew has
been waiting in front of the line here
at the Apple Store since about 4:00 a.m.
but we hear that there are people who've
been here since a wins day let's talk to
someone who won't find out I'm here with
Dale Larson he's been here since what
Wednesday night Wednesday night and
hustle weather
the weather's actually great it's nice
warm a little windy last night but and
you're getting sleep and food and
everything you need I'm doing it in
style I've got the tent in the air
mattress I'm getting great sleep but
lots of food I brought MREs but people
are bringing me hot food
you know pizza whatever else if you're
not going to do it in style a lot of
them do it there weren't that maybe 50
of 65s but now there's like 300 people
or something I've never waited in line
you can you're gonna be able to get one
today if you're not waiting in line
probably great that's always wanted to
light on the street downtown you know I
had a very sir
so I hear that until like 3:00 or 4:00
a.m. last night there were only like 30
or 40 people in line so was it worth it
to wait that long well the line was
surprisingly short I was a little
disappointed too you know feeling lonely
thirty people out here but sure it was
worth it I mean part of the point of
doing something like this is just have
fun were you doing while you are in the
line so we're with Robert Scoble a
famous blogger Robert they toured the
street please don't block the traffic
she made it in I made it in and the
servers are slow apparently he's trying
to enter my information for the fourth
time and see if he can get it to go
through looks like they're gonna be a
lot of discipline and people in this
line today what we're hearing is that
people are having trouble activating
their phones both in the Apple store and
in the AT&T store the lines actually are
a little bit shorter at the AT&T store
so that's the place to go if you want to
get an iPhone the problem is you're not
going to be able to use it as a phone
today or at least until later today if
these activation problems continue well
they couldn't activate it actually they
said to just go ahead and go home and
take it over that I did so I'm going to
go to work and so you've got an iPhone
but you can't actually use it yet music